السلام عليكم خيو
كيفكم
شفتوا خالتي شي ولا لا
صعبه
منذ ان دمر الزلزال قريه احمد بيه في
انطاكيا وهو يقضي معظمه وقته بالاتصال بمن
يمكن بحثا عن عشرات المفقودين من اصدقائه
وعائلته من بينهم خالته من محله في منطقه
كريتباك وسط يعني بنت عمي وحده منهم
وخالتي هلا راحوا يدوروا عليها واصحابي
يعني كتير هلا اغلبيه اصحابنا وخوات
على هاتفه صوره بلدته المدمره وابني خالته
الذي يبحث عن والدته بين الركام
ين كلهم بتقول امي يعني هلا قبل شوي حكيت
مع عمي
يعني كل يوم
ميتين لهون وعم ندفنونه هيك يعني البلده
يقول احمد تركت بمفردها منذ يوم زلزال ولم
يكن قد وصل اليها لا مسعفون ولا مساعدات
لحد هلا ما حدا بس كل واحد لحاله
يعني كيف يعني شو بيطلع بايدهم
ان يسافر الى تركيا ليساعد عائلته ولكنه
غير واثق النمته وكيف يمكنه الوصول وسط
الضمائر المحيطي ببلدته راغب بهنام
العربيه برلين